hello again england's remaining coveted
restrictions are being lifted from
tomorrow including the legal requirement
to self-isolate the world health
organization special envoy for kovit 19.
that's dr david nabarro who is with us
now um hello to doctors always great to
see you thank you for joining us um has
the government gone too far in lifting
all of these restrictions
i think that actually i'm quite
impressed by
really what's happening because
there is real a stress on continued
prudence in the face of the virus and
that is what's going to be needed to
live with the covid and prevent it from
coming back and causing trouble it's
going to be a bumpy journey moving from
where we were to where we need to be
and i do urge everybody to remember that
this virus is still around it can surge
sometimes dramatically so do what you
can to prevent transmitting it to others
especially if you feel unwell if you're
not required to isolate i still
encourage you to do so i also encourage
you to protect people who are at risk
older people and people with diseases
but perhaps most importantly because
this virus surges do prepare for the
probability that it will surge again but
overall we have to get on with life we
have to live with it and uh
perhaps we we do have to learn to do it
without restrictions from on high we
just got to do it working amongst
ourselves
and what about dropping testing is that
a good idea
well i must say that i've believed in
the british approach to testing being
really right at the front end of what
needs to be done i know people who've
had lateral flow tests and been able to
check their covert status before they go
to work every day and people who use
their covid checks to see whether
they're infected before they go to
social events and it really has been
useful at reducing the risk so i i do
hope that people can still access tests
and that those who really need them and
can't afford them will not be prevented
from doing so
if we don't have testing how do you find
new variants that's very difficult i
think that one of the good pieces of
news that i read from the uk is that
there is a plan to continue the
surveillance systems that have been used
to pick up new variants and uh you can't
actually check for a variant on lateral
flow testing but if you've got a well
organized set set of laboratories that
are doing uh further analysis of test
samples from people around the country
that helps you pick them up so yes
testing i mean if there's not testing
it's very difficult to take the uk
strategy to its limits and i i suppose
i'm hopeful that the people who can't
afford tests will still be able to get
them
but people are not going to go for a pcr
test are they um unless um they think
that they have got covid and the way to
have done that previously was to with
these lateral flow tests so the only way
i'm guessing that we'll pick it up is
through random testing for people who
are traveling
i think it will be uh random testing for
people who are traveling it'll be more
people coming into hospital in a
particular area and picked up with their
covid there it may be gp sounding the
alarm because they see more people being
ill in their surgeries or it may be just
a lot of absenteeism uh about for people
because you do still feel pretty rotten
when you get covered so absenteeism in
schools or in uh workplaces
without testing of the kind that britain
has had it's much harder you know the
virus is the problem people are the
solution if you want to solve the
problem you need to know where the virus
is and so your question about free
testing i know it's government policy
but my my approach would be to try to
keep the tests being available
particularly for those who can't afford
them particularly for those who are at
risk like security staff people working
in public transport and of course health
workers and what would you do about
passenger location forms um doctor i
mean they've been a pain at the best of
times for people and it's been
questionable how effective they have
been and yet despite all of the other
sanctions and regulations being lifted
restrictions they're still in place
yes i i noticed that too
you use passenger locator forms in case
there is a
person with covid picked up on a flight
and you want to find the other
passengers to get hold of them quickly
they're quite a useful part of the
process of tracing where people are when
they're ill
i'd certainly
expect them to continue but i that's why
i also favor maintaining capacity for
contact tracing when you do get a
cluster of cases as a disease outbreak
drops and the numbers of cases reduce
so it becomes more and more important to
be able to do the detective work so that
if you are getting some cases appearing
you can quickly pinpoint where
they're coming from so these kinds of
things like passenger locator forms or
contact tracing systems are particularly
useful in the uh
the downward slope of an outbreak curve
sorry for being technical
perhaps okay but i mean we'd only know
if there was a cluster of cases if
people were poorly enough to either go
to the doctor or to find themselves in
hospital is that not right that's right
so there are parts of what's happening
in not just the uk but in many countries
that are leaving me wondering a bit uh
why they're making these decisions
the basic situation is that as you
emerge from a nasty pandemic or outbreak
the the the emergency is always bumpy
it's always difficult and people are
incredibly frustrated and want to get on
with their lives governments want to get
people moving forward and and the
economic recovery in place but it's
during that time that you really do need
to know what's going on so i suppose if
i had a magic wand
and i wasn't worried about what the
treasury would say i would try to
maintain things like free testing just
through this period until the number of
cases really is down because if you
don't know where the virus is if you
don't know who's ill if you don't know
which parts of the country have got
surges it's super difficult for people
to make informed choices which is what i
understand the uk government and other
european governments are asking their
people to do